[Music]
flying Hawks all sitting on a horse is
just not something I ever imagined I
would do but I definitely feel like I
could be some kind of like medieval
badass princess just like galloping
through the hills with a hawk on my arm
[Music]
I'm very much a horse girl I grew up in
a barn pretty much so it kind of my
element Carrie nice to meet you
falconry from horseback was a sport that
was popular across medieval Europe but
today it's incredibly rare unless you're
in Central Asia I kind of stumbled upon
and start more hopping and thought it
would just be an incredible opportunity
to learn how to fly a hawk or a falcon
while sitting on a horse it's just not
something many people get to do where I
come from doing probably four horses
very much from hunting with them
background and up on top we got big open
spaces the hosts really enhance your
fall three one thousand five hundred and
sixty pounds she's about spot-on
the birds are too fat they're gonna have
no motivation fly to you so we're
relying on the hunting mystic now I need
stress it's not starvation but you've
got to have an appetite
[Music]
when the birds have the hood on like
Martin said if they fly away then like
they could die because they effectively
can't see so my biggest fear is that I'm
gonna accidentally let a bird loose
while it has its hood on and I kill one
of these birds
[Music]
well now I probably should have warned
you before I put him there
if you wanted to he could put those
talents for your glove okay he's not
going to he's not going to just I just
say you're where the capability is what
you're dealing with if you're not stable
perch he's not gonna want anything to do
with you because you're breaking your
side of relationship which is a safe
place to be he seems like someone who is
in it because he loves what he's doing
it's very much not for show which is
something I was looking for and just
hearing him talk about the horses and
talk about the bird it's kind of like
he's talking about an old friend I know
she's it wait she's not Miss Piggy brain
yes she will quite happy hunting time
she'll take that idea kill her
[Music]
it just feels really cool and just
weirdly natural I'm a huge animal person
so I think that's why is that like I
went into this knowing that I wanted to
get in like get close to the birds and
like I'm fine with the dogs running
around and like meeting the horses the
horses Martin you took falconry are all
thoroughbred so these are horses that
are bred and designed for speed and so
not only is he using thoroughbreds that
he uses retired x-ray sources so these
are horses that have been trained to go
fast train to win races but then once
their racing career is over he works to
rehome them and train them how to be
thoughtful well are you feeling bright
yeah I mean I think it was really cool
that the eagle has never flown from a
horse before so I was the first person
to ever introduce him to a new thing so
it's kind of like we were getting to
learn together which I never expected
it's kind of the thing you see in a
nature documentary not in real life a
bird that's just flown from right around
you so it was just absolutely beautiful
to see him just soaring toward the
horizon even though it wasn't supposed
to go that way that wasn't supposed to
happen
Wow it was amazing I mean I would love
to do this again it's just you know kind
of barking home and I don't think my
horse would be okay when the hawk
landing on his
it's not something you do every day
[Music]
you